i have some absolute must-see tv for you
today i want to bring you just one
critical analysis
of a single person claiming voter fraud
and the reason i'm going to do this is
that very often when we hear about
the supposedly endless just gobs of
people
claiming voter fraud proving that joe
biden didn't really win
we might think well there must be
something to it right i mean
countless affidavits as they are talking
about these
these must really be something if there
are so many of them and often when this
happens what you have to do it's much
like
when someone gish gallops you during a
debate meaning throwing
10 12 14 different arguments at you
until you slow down
and look at each argument's merits one
by one
it can seem like there's a case so let's
do the equivalent here let's look at
just
one of these claims of voter fraud
bearing in mind that this one presumably
is one that
is more credible because fox news chose
this uh person whose video i'm going to
play for you in a moment
as the person to bring on tv so this is
melissa carone
this is a supposed whistleblower imagine
calling her that after you watch
this video and melissa carone was
brought on to fox news
actually it was fox business not fox
news fox business is the
less watched sister channel to fox news
and melissa carone was interviewed by
lou dobbs now i'm not going to give you
any more
let's just start watching and hear the
explosive story of voter fraud or fraud
as trump says
claimed by melissa carone this is one of
the people who signed one of these
powerful affidavits testifying to the
voter fraud
my challenge to you is follow the story
i challenge you to follow her story take
a look let me start with
the most egregious part of what i read
in
your of your affidavit multiple
counts of the same ballots how did that
happen
so the workers are handed a
ballots in stacks of 50s
they are referred to as batches and
they run them through the tabulators
when the ballot has any kind of a mark
on it
it'll stop the the tabulator will stop
completely
and the computer will put up an error
and it'll say
you know ballot number 25
has an error and so
the process would be to take ballot
number 25
as well as all of the other ballots that
had already went through the tabulator
off put them back in a pile
put ballot number 25 on top of the stack
discard the whole batch and rescan it
and that's and instead they went through
that process several times
so
[Laughter]
one of the funniest parts of this
interview is
listening to lou dobbs try to understand
what on earth
this woman is talking about certainly
it's unclear to me what she's talking
about i'm guessing it's unclear to you
but it's unclear even to lou dobbs who
booked this interview for his show so so
far
we have no smoking gun not even really
an allegation of a smoking gun so far
it's we we've heard about you know
nothing really and this continues
and it becomes even more laughable if
you can imagine and when lou dobbs
asks melissa carone to talk about
the night shift and the food delivery
vans
it goes completely off the rails uh the
describe the night shift chaos that you
described
uh food
food vans apparently showing up but not
with food but
with uh ballots uh apparently uh give us
a sense of what happened
there so they're um so i worked a
24-hour shift
i started at 6 00 a.m and i got off at 6
00 p.m or 6 a.m
the next day so i started
at 6 a.m november 3rd got off at
6 00 am november 4th
so i was there during their day shift
and their night shift
um the city provides the workers with
food for their shift well they only had
enough food for
one-third of their workers
so that is the reason why they
were claiming that these vans were were
brought in
but these vans did not have taken out of
so here is where it looks like lou dobbs
starts to realize
why am i interviewing this woman right
now what the what the hell
is this about and it gets even more
funny guys
the vans didn't have enough food
listen to lou dobbs just try to make
sense of this and he can't he's visibly
struggling
but these vans did not have taken out of
them
and the vans the vans that showed up
they were supposed to be filled with
food what did what did they have in them
do you know i never saw
anything being brought out of the vans i
know that whatever was being
brought out of the vans was being
brought out of the back of the vans
but um i was not allowed over in that
area at all
but the vans were definitely not big
enough to be carrying
enough food for two-thirds of those
workers don't you understand guys
in the middle of a 24-hour shift melissa
carone
saw vans show up she doesn't know what
was in the vans
she saw nothing but is sure
that the vans did not have food
for two-thirds of the workers and
what so what watch lou dobbs then try to
wrap this up with melissa carone
well it it's all very suspicious it is
very clear that you have witnessed
highly irregular uh activities in that
accounting session and david i want to
turn to you
uh how well protected is
is melissa lou dobbs they're able to say
only
that it is suspicious and irregular
what she saw but why what what's so
suspicious here so
understand how many layers removed we
are
from any allegations that something was
actually going wrong here
they want to go to i saw vans but not
what was in them
at strange times of day without food for
everyone
they want to go from that to the results
in michigan must be fraudulent and trump
really won
what and as you can imagine fox news
and fox business did not continue
interviewing these
affidavit signers because it went really
really poorly they switched instead to
interviewing you know trump's lawyers
sydney powell and
continuing to interview rudy giuliani
interviewing trump campaign staffers
it's almost a joke like if saturday
night live were to make a skit
of this it would be this there's the you
it's indistinguishable from parody
listen i was in there they had no kosher
meal
for the poll workers they had no vegan
meal
for the vegan poll workers it's very
suspicious lou
well that's certainly uh highly
irregular melissa
it's crazy that these are the people
that they are basing their allegations
of voter fraud on whacked she was not
invited back i don't think it will uh
it will surprise you let's now keep
talking a little bit about what we've
been seeing on fox news
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time
check out one of my all-time favorite
apps called
blinkist blinkist lets you consume an
entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video